ist einfach den gott verdammt längste
command den ich je irgendwie gesehen
habe
hallo geht steht gut oder filmstar noch
ich weiß nicht wieso ich müde aussehe
ich habe bis 13 uhr geschlafen aber
irgendwie war das wohl zu viel schlaf
aber hannah hat freuen und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einem kleinen video
heute hier am dienstag ich gebe mir
schon mal einen command block und zwar
habe ich ja gesagt dass ich ein bisschen
flexibler sein möchte was so serien
angeht die ich öfters mal mache und hab
ich mir gedacht dass freitags immer halt
immer noch die commands kommen
allerdings ich dann am dienstag immer
noch so einen command vorstelle der
entweder zu langen für die commands am
freitag ist oder zu groß oder zu viele
sachen hinzufügt dafür dass er dann zu
lang sein wird und
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich werde
das ganze dann einfach mal immer am
dienstag machen dass ich euch da einmal
so ein command vorstelle der entweder
halt extrem viel zu lange das oder halt
viel zu viele eltern zufügt und da
kommen wir heute dazu und zwar zu dem
bisher längsten kommentar die nicht bzw
längsten command den ich je irgendwo
entdeckt habe und zwar seht ihr schon
für diesen command brauche ich nicht nur
einen command bloggt er dann weitere
command blogs generiert sondern drei
command command blogs ich finde
natürlich die pace pin in der
beschreibung des wassers seien erdbeben
eckhard craig auf englisch command von
phoenix ssc und zwar muss sich nach
norden schauen also wenn ihr f3 drückte
da hier facing nord da muss ich ihn
schon drei nebeneinander platzieren in
die mitte einen button setzen und dann
muss hier links das eingefügt werden ihr
seht schon wie viele zeichen da wohl
drin sind wenn der so oft wieder beendet
werden muss der command sage ich mal
dann muss ich jetzt mal eben schnell
noch mal in meinen dass pace bin
formular gehen und wieder was kopieren
ich konnte mich nicht alles auf einmal
kopieren weil es einfach so viel ist
dann treibt nämlich auf den in der mitte
zugang ist dass hier wieder neues
programm jetzt zurück scorer mit dem man
sieht hier komme ich es wohl die ganze
nach hinten und erst hier ist an der
command wieder also ich könnte jetzt
circa zehn jahre weiter scrollen ihr
habt es wahrscheinlich offenbar gesehen
ist es einfach der gott verdammt längste
command den ich je irgendwie gesehen
habe so da haben wir das jetzt in den
zweiten command eine in den zweiten
block eingefügte weht schon hier was in
dem in dem dings hier drin steht das ist
schon recht viel oder greifen wir auf
dem command blog als rechts und geben
dass wieder eine trophäe wieder ganz fit
und wir haben jetzt insgesamt diese
ganzen command sie drin das ist sogar
nur ein teil davon das geht eigentlich
noch viel höher
es geht noch viel viel höher dass es
viel mehr apps wahrscheinlich auf den
sammler gesehen oder ich blende euch
jetzt einfach mal ein bild an wie groß
dieser ganze koma einfache und zwar
deshalb bei dem command wichtig dass ihr
euch wirklich nach norden gerichtet wenn
ihr das ganze macht und dass sie eine
1.8 punkt 1 spielt weil als ich es
gemacht habe war ich in der 1.8 war ich
ja immer mit shader aufnehme und da hat
es nicht geklappt
jedenfalls meine freunde wir drücken
jetzt einfach auf den button und ihr
seht schon es wird sehr sehr viel
kreiert hier sind sehr viele command
blogs enthalten phoenix scr kat 15
phoenix heimste das ist ein youtube
kanal von respawn close to sea level
away from any loss of motorsports videos
black and cost of destruction yes to
this caution es des is very happy happy
bradley smith redstone blog des staates
kontraktion approximation trip als
second scale local heißt also es ist
vorhersehbar dass es ganz 15 sekunden
dauert bis das ganze fällig ist und so
aber heute wir wo wir nehmen uns
natürlich hier einen redstone block und
replay zumal das glas damit so und jetzt
schon ich habe einen riesigen command
wieder damit ausgelöst und ihr seht
schon in meinem in meinem inventar
initiiert craig also erst craig
erschaffen provozieren mehr oder weniger
ich würde sagen wir klicken damit jetzt
einfach mal hier auf den boden und ich
habe hier schon perfekte langsamkeit
resistenz läuft models tempel inka ist
sofort was passiert dir mal was ist das
jetzt das ist doch nicht wahr es ist
einfach alles total am zoom und
irgendwie ich rückl nicht nett das ist
alles zu hier einmal so ein bisschen
amor nachbeben freunde nach dem alter
[ __ ] es ist ja die ganze amt doch weil
das denn jetzt immer vorbei sagt ich
glaube jetzt ist vorbei oder war durch
geber kurz wieder in den games so viel
ich immer raus und ihr seht schon damit
habe ich jetzt quasi hier soll es ein
erdbeben verursacht und ihr seht schon
es ist nicht ganz normal wie so ein
meteor ball den ich irgendwo hinwerfen
da kommt feuer unseren umkreis sondern
es ist wirklich ein erdbeben also wir
sehen hier
er nimmt die blöcke die hier unten sind
schiebt die quasi nach außen und schieb
dich hier an die seite hin also ihr seht
schon da ist quasi wie erdbeben immer
wenn es die erde besteht aus
verschiedenen platten und wenn die
platten aneinander
oder aneinander ziehen oder so denn es
entstehen halt dieser erdbeben weil die
halt aneinander knirschen sage ich mal
das ist sie wieder erdkunde mit luca
aber ganz ganz schlecht erklärte freunde
das sieht einfach extrem schön aus kann
man das einfach sonne sand höhle und her
wie geil ist das denn
ja ich denke ihr versteht was ich sagen
möchte zwar ist es einfach unseren
erdbeben das halt nicht einfach so an
der explosion hat sondern was einfach
auch total ukulele was halt wirklich so
aussieht wie sein erdbebens nimmt quasi
die blöcke von außen und schmeißt die so
nach außen
das gleiche kann ich euch dies nimmt die
blöcke von außen schmeißt doch auch sehr
gut luca soll ist eigentlich nicht bei
wasser machen und hier ist ein bisschen
wasser aber ich mache jetzt einfach mal
und drücke hier noch mal initiiert break
ich kann ehrlich hochfliegen versucht
man in den game ort einzugehen und nehme
ich glaube den aspekt kann ich auch gar
nicht in den game und 1 gegen ich
versuche ja so was ist das denn ihr
alter das ist wieder total ist es vorbei
ist
es ist noch nicht vorbei da jetzt vorbei
freude jetzt können wir in ingame hat
eins gemein das ganze vorbei ist und ihr
seht ihr schon das ganze funktioniert
natürlich auch hier ist nimmt quasi die
blöcke von der mitte und schiebt sie
nach außen sowie beim erdbeben einfach
kennen sie wenn du aus dem film 2012 wo
dieser erdbeben sind und viele leute vor
allem diese spalte reihen
so ähnlich ist es halt hier ist nimmt
quasi die blöcke aus der mitte und
schiebt die nach außen so als wenn der
sonne erbt hat auseinander rutschen
würde würde es wäre noch viel viel
geiler wenn das ganze dann wirklich so
aussehen würde die sonne minecraft
schlucht also wenn es noch viel viel
tiefer gehen würde und nicht nur so
komisch ja aber das ist eigentlich schon
der komplette command ich freunde ich
als jemand der sich mit command nur ein
bisschen auskennen also ich weiß ein
bisschen was execute heute zu sammeln
und die ganze kaka also ich bin jetzt
echt ein kompletter nook drin eigentlich
verstehe ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz wieso
das ganze ding so ein riesiger command
ist aber
es gibt quasi nur blöcke nach außen sage
ich mal und macht noch so ein paar
effekte
ich weiß nicht dieser kultroman so lang
ist ich möchte nicht in command
hersteller angehen weil es ist ein sehr
cooler command und dadurch dass er man
halt dazu oft viel erzählen kann und der
command halte aber auch so lang ist und
er vor allem auch in der 1.8 und ein
spiel da hatte ich keine lust sich in
der freitags version dran zu nehmen wo
ich immer 3,1 vorstellen die man den 18
machen kann dann müsste ich dann die
spielversion wechseln und dann wieder
alles kopieren dann wird es jetzt zehn
jahre dauern
deswegen habe ich euch dafür heute noch
vorgestellt allerdings freunde bevor
sagt hey heute nur ein kurzes video nein
heute abend kommt noch ein gaming video
ich bin wieder am vorproduzieren weil
viele events sind beispielsweise beim
let's play pokal bin ich dabei und so
weiter und so fort
und da muss ich selbst produzieren
deswegen hoffe ich euch wäre
veröffentlicht